[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon and welcome.
I'm Tomiko Brown-Nagin, the
dean of the Radcliffe Institute.
And we are delighted to have
all of you here with us today.
Let me start by thanking
VIDA, women in literary arts,
for partnering with
the Schlesinger
Library on the History of
Women to organize this event.
And of course, I'm grateful
to this remarkable group
of panelists and our
distinguished moderator
for agreeing to participate
in what promises
to be a fascinating discussion.
Today's program is a part
of a yearlong celebration
of the 75th anniversary of
the Schlesinger Library.
And I understand that we're also
marking the 10th anniversary
of the VIDA Count, an
annual inventory of gender
disparity in major literary
publications and book reviews.
Here at Radcliffe and
at VIDA, too, I imagine,
anniversaries are about
more than commemoration.
They're are also
about taking stock.
They provide an opportunity
to reflect on progress,
but also to chart
the work ahead,
the work towards the objectives
that we've set for our society
and for ourselves as advocates
of equality and opportunity
for all.
For that reason, I'm thrilled
that today's panel will focus
our attention on feminisms
now, where we find ourselves
and where we aim to go.
Over the next few
years, we at Radcliffe
will engage in more of
this kind of taking stock
as we critically examine the
centennial of women's suffrage
in the United States.
And on Monday, October 29, we
will continue our Schlesinger
75th anniversary programming
with a performance
from Shaina Taub's important
new musical, The Suffragist,
followed by a panel discussion.
I hope many of you will
register online and join us
for that event.
And now it's my
distinct pleasure
to turn things over
to Jane Kamensky, who
will introduce our panel.
Jane is the Pforzheimer
Foundation director
of the Schlesinger Library here
at Radcliffe and the Trumbull
Professor of American History
in the faculty of Arts
and Sciences.
Jane.
[APPLAUSE]
-
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you, Tomiko.
This is, as Tamiko said, part
of our 75th anniversary year.
It's our first public
event of the year.
It's the first public gathering
in the renovated Knafel Center.
So if you smell
off-gassing, it's
all from very green materials.
Don't worry about that.
And it's also Tomiko's first
public event as our new dean,
so welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
So looking back to look forward.
The anniversary
commemorates the founding
in 1943 of Radcliffe College's
Women's Rights Collection,
which then consisted of about
30 cartons of manuscripts
and several hundred
printed volumes.
The Women's Rights
Collection came out
of what has come to be
known as the first wave
of American feminism,
the decades of activism
from the second quarter
of the 19th century
into the early decades
of the 20th, which
culminated in the 1920s
passage of the 19th Amendment
to the US Constitution,
declaring that the right
to vote in the United States
could not be abridged by sex.
The amendment, of
course, enfranchised
only those American women
who were not already
denied the vote
by virtue of race,
national origin, territorial
residence, disability,
and other qualifiers.
By the 1950s, Schlesinger's
women's suffrage collections
were very strong,
nearly peerless.
Only Sophia Smith's special
collections could rival them.
But the library
grew quite slowly
until the gathering of a second
wave of American feminism
beginning in the 1960s.
The thinkers, activists,
and organizations
of the second wave
wanted to be sure
that their legacies
would be preserved
in libraries and in archives.
And many of them joined
forces with Schlesinger.
Our second-wave collections
span and sometimes
bridge the many
schisms of that era.
We include the papers of
liberal and radical feminists,
of white and
African-American activists,
of queer and straight thinkers,
of anti-pornography and pro-sex
feminists, and so on.
So we hold, to name just a few,
the papers of Betty Friedan,
of Susan Brownmiller,
of Adrienne Rich,
of June Jordan, Andrea Dworkin,
Catharine MacKinnon, Florence
Kennedy, and as of last
January, Angela Davis,
as well as the organizational
records of NOW and NOW
Legal Defense and
Education Fund, of Women
Against Pornography, and of
the Boston Women's Health Book
Collective.
For several decades
now, scholars
of the history of
women and gender
have questioned the very
idea of feminist waves, which
have never been as unified
or as discrete or as clear
in their swelling and breaking
as the wave metaphor suggests.
Nonetheless, it's been
obvious for some time
that the so-called
second wave is over,
having reached its sell-by
date long before the 2016
presidential election.
Through its strengths
and its faults,
the second wave has
given rise or given way
to subsequent forms
of feminist activism.
Today's emerging feminists, the
fourth or maybe the fifth wave
by some reckonings, have fresh
energies and different ways
of viewing the world than their
predecessors sometimes did.
Their intellectual and
institutional relationships
to those predecessors
is, I think
it's safe to say, mixed, a
blend of homage and critique
that any movement
needs to remain vital.
The commitments,
priorities, hopes and fears
of millennial feminists and
their links to the commitments,
priorities, hopes and fears
of the second wave and indeed
the first, are our subject
here this afternoon.
What batons have
been passed and which
have been dropped
between the generations?
How have rising
feminists shined light
into the blind spots
of their forebears.
And also in turn, what did the
instigators of the second wave
know that we may be at
risk of forgetting today?
As we turn toward another
important moment for women,
for voters to use or
lose the franchise
and the rights that go
with it, and as libraries
like ours begin to collect
the records of Gen Y
and of millennials, getting
a handle on these questions
seem important.
Populating and framing
today's discussion
came out of a team
effort, as Tomiko
said, between a classically
second-wave organization
and a millennial one.
Schlesinger Library and the
New York-based nonprofit VIDA,
Women and the Literary Arts.
VIDA is a feminist
organization committed
to creating transparency
around the lack of gender
parity in the literary
landscape and to amplifying
historically marginalized
voices, including people
of color, writers
with disability,
and queer, trans, and gender
non-conforming individuals.
The VIDA Count, VIDA's
flagship program,
now marking its
10th anniversary,
highlights gender
imbalances in publishing
by tallying genre, book
reviewers, books reviewed,
and journalistic bylines to
offer a data-driven assessment
of the publishing world.
Through the VIDA Count, along
with the online publication
of VIDA Review and
initiatives like #saferlit,
VIDA aims to stimulate
thoughtful conversation
about the challenges faced
by marginalized populations
within the literary community
and beyond with hopes
of enabling a more
inclusive literary culture.
In recent years, VIDA has
added race, disability,
sexual identity, and age
to the categories counted.
The count has been
widely acknowledged
by myriad national
news outlets as one
of the only and most
reliable sources
on gender disparity
in the literary world.
It has also moved the needle
on many important publications,
except those which are
unrepentant resisters.
[LAUGHTER]
The men's review of books,
as I like to call it.
I want to thank VIDA board
members Melissa Febos
and Hafizah Geter for their
help curating this stellar group
of panelists.
I'll introduce them
all now in the order
in which they'll speak.
So first up will be the
poet Fatimah Asghar,
the writer and
co-creator of Brown Girls
an Emmy-nominated web series
centered on friendships
between women of color,
which is in development
for television with HBO.
Asghar's debut collection of
poems, If They Come For Us,
which she has a copy of
in front of her right now,
was published by the One
World imprint of Random House
just last month.
It explores her
unique subjectivity
as a Pakistani Muslim American
at times of peril and fracture
in her home country, especially
around the time of partition,
and in today's United States.
Starred reviews in
Publishers Weekly
and in the Library
Journal hail her voice
as at once fierce and
tender, personal, powerful,
and political.
She is also a graduate of
Cambridge Rindge and Latin High
School.
[APPLAUSE]
Some of whose
students and faculty
are here today to
hear and pay tribute
to their famous forebear.
Writer and legal
activist Dana Bolger
is co-founder of
the organization
Know Your IX, a national
youth-led movement
that educates and
empowers students
to end gender violence in
their schools and beyond.
Founded in 2013, Know Your
IX works with high school
and with college
students, training
them to combat gender
discrimination, including
sexual violence.
Bolger also serves
as a senior editor
at Feministing, a leading
online community run
by and for young feminists.
She has testified
before Congress
on sexual assault policy
and legislative reform.
And her writing has
appeared in the New York
Times, the Washington Post,
and The Wall Street Journal,
among other outlets.
Melissa Febos,
assistant professor
of creative writing at
Monmouth University,
is the author of the memoir
Whip Smart, published
in 2010, and the essay
collection Abandon Me,
published in 2017, which the
New Yorker called "mesmerizing,"
and which was a Lambda Literary
Award finalist, a Triangle
Publishing Award
finalist, an Indie Next
pick, and a named
best book of 2017
by an astonishing
range of publications,
including Esquire, Book Riot,
The Cut, Electric Literature,
The Brooklyn Rail,
Bustle, Refinery29, Salon,
and The Rumpus.
I don't think there are
many people who have
reached Esquire and The Rumpus.
The inaugural winner of the
Jeanne Cordova Nonfiction
Prize from Lambda
Literary, Febos
will publish a second
essay collection, Girlhood,
with Bloomsbury in 2020.
A cultural critic,
Kim Foster founded
For Harriet, an online community
of women of African ancestry,
founded it back in 2010 while
she was an undergraduate right
here at Harvard.
Welcome back, Kim.
For Harriet has since seeded
three sister sites, Soar,
Shine, and The Culture.
The aim of these
communities is, quote,
"to raise the level of discourse
surrounding black womanhood."
The For Harriet sites
have become premier spaces
for black women's
journalism and storytelling
and have been featured
in the New York
Times and other
national media outlets.
Kim has written for The
Guardian and for Newsweek
and has appeared widely
on television and radio.
Two years ago, Forbes
magazine named Foster
to its national
30 under 30 list.
Finally, Emi Koiama,
activist, writer,
and self-described
rogue intellectual,
is the author of the pioneering
Transfeminist Manifesto
and other essays of
transfeminism, published back
in 1999.
This is very early for
transfeminist writing.
The Manifesto has circulated
both as an underground text
and in published versions
for nearly two decades.
We have become
increasingly aware
that the diversity of women is
our strength, not our weakness,
Koiama writes in that manifesto.
Koiama's transfeminism
and her activism
more broadly embraces what
she calls feminist coalition
projects in which women
from different backgrounds
stand up for each other.
Koiama is a multi-issue
social justice activist,
synthesizing feminist,
Asian, survivor, dyke, queer,
sex worker, intersect,
genderqueer,
and [? crypt ?] politics.
When I asked her about her
pronoun preferences for this
introduction, she wrote, and I
quote-- and she said I could--
"I don't subscribe to
the neoliberal politics
of preferred pronouns
that reduces gender
to a mere matter of
individual preferences, which
is deeply troubling
to me as a feminist,"
something that we can talk
about later this afternoon.
Koiama currently serves
as the coordinatrix
of the Seattle-based Coalition
for the Rights and Safety
for People in the Sex Trade.
After each panelist
speaks briefly
about their work, my
colleague, Robert Reid-Pharr
will moderate a discussion among
them before turning to Q and A
from the audience.
Reid-Pharr, who served for
many years as distinguished
and Presidential Professor of
English and American studies
at CUNY Graduate Center recently
joined the Harvard faculty
as Professor of Women,
Gender, and Sexuality.
His is the first appointment,
first senior appointment,
to lie solely within
the WGS program
and is a real achievement
for us to have him here.
Welcome, Robert.
[APPLAUSE]
An eminent feminist theorist
and cultural critic,
Reid-Pharr is the author of
four books on race, gender,
and sexuality in
American culture,
including Archives of
Flesh, published in 2016,
and Black Gay Man, a collection
of essays published in 2001.
At Harvard, his courses include
race, gender, and the archive.
He is working on a
biography of James Baldwin.
And with that, I will turn
it over to Fatimah Asghar
to kick off what I know will
be a stimulating discussion.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
- [INAUDIBLE].
Can you guys hear me?
Does this work?
Yes.
OK.
Thank you all so much for
having me, for being here.
It really means a
lot to me, especially
having gone to Rindge and
when I was in high school,
I used to work here.
And it's really
amazing to be here.
So I'm going to read them
poems and talk a little bit.
This poem is called
"National Geographic."
"I see my not-me on the news,
she who weds for her sweet 16.
Mosquito bites for breasts.
My not-khaala's trace her
hands with mehndi, a plate
of mathai bursting at her feet.
My not-khalu's dance pound palm
to drum, stave off monsoons.
My not-abbu checks the
sheets for her blood
the morning after, brandishes
the satin like a flag,
his pride singing
through the town.
There is my not-me
again, the one I
could have been, drowned in a
burqa on her way to the market,
fingering mangoes
through gloves,
nihari steaming for
hours at the flat shared
with my not-husband's family.
My not-me's eyes,
brilliant and green,
decorating the pages
of Western magazines,
eyes that earn a white man
awards and showings, but eyes
that stay [INAUDIBLE]
in the mountains
while my not-me rims her
son's mouth with salt to trick
his belly into not hunger.
My not-me celebrating
Diwali, lights
gathered at the
base of her door.
My not-me Indian worshipping
a host of different gods,
calling all their names.
My not-tongue not foreign,
not accented, not strange.
My not-me not worried
about Taliban,
but still worried about men.
My not-me on the bus,
divided among the passengers
hands, abdomen gutted,
left on a road to die.
Still not me alone and not me."
So I think that when
I think about feminism
and how it relates to my
work, I think about the ways
that my work tries
really hard to grapple
a lot with
intersectional identity
and giving the space to
have a full breadth of one's
humanity, which I think is
sometimes really difficult when
you're a person who comes from
a background or backgrounds that
are intersecting and
when people kind of try
to categorize or pigeon-hole
you into being one thing
and don't really allow
you the space of really
being a full human.
And thinking about, too--
so I work as a poet,
and I'm also a screenwriter.
And I think a lot
about the way that we
develop characters in screen.
And a lot of times the way that
folks talk about developing
characters is they'll be like,
well, here's a character.
This is their backgrounds.
These are the issues
that they face.
And this is that, which
to me always rings
super hollow when you
then go to screen and see
that kind of beings displayed.
The reason why is it doesn't
give space for humanity.
It doesn't give
space for someone
to just be a full person.
And I think sometimes
when I think
about the danger of when we
talk about representation,
especially when we
talk about filmmaking
or when we talk about poetry
and we talk about art,
is when you talk
about representation
and you kind of reduce it
down to just that and you
don't allow for the reasons
why representation is important
and the reasons why it's
important to have people who
come from the backgrounds
of the characters
that they're writing
write those backgrounds
and to kind of give
them that fullness
and that sense of complexity
that sometimes missing.
So I think that it's interesting
because a lot of times
I'm asked about things
about representation.
And it's hard, because I think
representation is really,
really important,
but I also think
it's a really hollow
concept when you just
treat it as representation
for representation's sake.
And so I really want to--
I think for me the thing
that really matters to me,
the thing that drives
a lot of my work,
is to really focus
in on the human
and thinking about
the pain and the joy
and the love of all
of those identities.
And I think for
so many of us who
come from marginalized
backgrounds,
we kind of come from this space
where people only talk about
your identity as a space of
trauma and as a space of pain
and of sadness and as a
lack, like you are this
because you lack whiteness.
You are this because
you lack maleness.
You are this because you lack
straightness, whatever that is.
And that's a really damaging
way of thinking about identity.
And it's a really,
really damaging thing
to be a person of color, to
be a woman of color, a queer
woman of color, and
have to kind of think
about yourself as a lack and
not from a positive [? sight. ?]
And so something that I
think about in my work
is to really not
let that happen,
to really not say that
I come from a lack
or I'm a lack of something but
that I'm actually a positive.
I exist in this positive space.
And that's not to say that
you can't you talk about pain.
That poem that I just read
had a lot of pain in it.
But thinking about what are the
complicated bonds of sisterhood
and intimacy formed from some
of these backgrounds and how
are those terrains
of joy and of love.
And how is that a specific
kind of love and joy
that other people
don't have access
to that we can celebrate?
So I'm going to read
another poem, which
is a poem that I wrote.
I did crew here on
the Charles River.
And this is a poem for the
people that I did crew with.
And it's called "To
Prevent Hypothermia."
"After the race, my teammates
kicked the boys off the bus
and into the downpour,
blocked the windows
with their sweatshirts, peeled
the wet clothes from my skin,
each inch matted down,
disobedient, hair
plastered to my brown legs.
It took two hungry girls
to remove the Spandex
from my paling thighs,
their blond hair a cascade
from heaven, water droplets
falling from their roots,
stinging my body.
The ports tore off my
shirts and sports bra.
And my nipples lighthouses
in a swole ocean,
a trail of dark hair
running up my belly.
My whole boat witness to
my small, naked frame,
a gulf of shiver on the bus.
And their own hairless legs
disappearing into their shorts,
skin ripe as peaches,
reaching for my brown body.
These girls who I
had stolen glances
at while we changed and wished I
could look like, my locker room
crew, my 5:00 AM practice girls,
my lean over the starboard side
so she could pee off
the rigger girls,
my two-mile run after eating
Annie's mac and cheese girls.
They took turns
rubbing life back
and my bones, offered
clothes off their own backs
to keep me from shaking.
My girls, sandwiching me in
their heat until my joints
flowered, until the warmth
blooded through my blood.
What more could
I ask than a team
willing to undress
their captain, too
cold and rain-glittered
to do it alone."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi, everybody.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm totally thrilled to be here
and feel completely humbled
and a little bit
intimidated to be here
with my amazing co-panelists.
I'm Dana.
I am a third-year in law school.
Before I went to law
school, I organized students
across the country to combat
sexual and gender violence
in our schools.
We passed good laws.
We defeated bad laws.
We organized for better policies
and practices in our schools.
And then we turned around and
trained the slightly younger
generation of [? next ?]
students to do the same.
And the idea wasn't just
to mobilize young people
on this one issue
of sexual violence
but frankly to politicize
them and to develop
their feminist
consciousness and endow them
with the tools and the
skills that they were going
to need to fight on any range of
progressive causes in the years
ahead.
Many of us in the contemporary
movement against gender
violence met online after
we formed secret Facebook
groups, groups with hundreds and
hundreds of survivors in them.
We shared tips there
about managing flashbacks
and crowdsourced
advice on dealing
with a hostile,
unresponsive legal system.
And in those Facebook
groups, we got angry.
We circulated older
feminist writings.
We planned protests.
It was a form of
consciousness-raising,
just online.
And dissatisfied with
the lack of resources
that were available to
us, we built our own.
So with no legal
background or degrees,
we built a website to share
with other students what
we had learned the hard
way about our own rights.
So this is all to say that my
small community and generation
of feminists have relied
in really large part
on the strategies and the tools
sharpened by the feminists who
came in the 50 years before us.
And it seems impossible
to me to talk
about the contemporary
movement against gender
violence in our schools without
talking about the second wave.
Title IX, the landmark
civil rights law
that, among other
things, requires schools
to respond to sexual
harassment and violence,
is itself, of course, a
product of the second wave.
And the core insight
of the second wave,
that the personal is political
and that private violence ought
to be a matter of
public concern,
lives on in our work today.
But the central question,
as many of us see it today,
is who should be
responsible for responding
to the harms of violence.
The white, mainstream
strand of the second wave,
which demanded that the state
take gender violence seriously
in the same way it took
other forms of violence
seriously through the
police and prisons
resulted in reforms ranging
from the criminalization
of marital rape to dual and
mandatory arrest policies.
And it coincided with the
rise of mass incarceration
and with the idea
that incarceration
should be the dominant
and the appropriate way
to address all sorts of problems
in our country, problems that
might otherwise have been
differently addressed
through, say, a
focus on education
or poverty or public health.
As my friend Alexandra
Brodsky puts it,
prisons really
came to monopolize
our imaginations of the
right way to respond to harm.
That's a legacy that many
of my peers want to undo.
For us, part of the
appeal of Title IX
has been its potential
to be an alternative
to the moral failure of the
criminal legal system, a system
that puts black and brown
men in cages, that threatens
undocumented victims with
deportation, that criminalizes
women of color when they fight
back against their abusers,
and that does nothing meaningful
to end sexual violence,
but actually fosters violence
against the people it's
supposed to house and reform.
So many young feminists are
asking the question if not
this system, then what?
What are the alternatives?
And that's a question
that women of color
have been asking for a
really, really long time
and that groups
like Insight have
been pioneering really
creative responses
to for a really long time.
But one alternative,
it seemed to my peers,
was to marshal civil
rights law, Title IX,
to require our
institutions to respond
to the harms we're facing.
Title IX prohibits sex
discrimination in education,
not just in colleges
and universities
as we hear about a lot, but
also in elementary schools
and middle schools
and high schools.
And because rape and harassment
can make it really hard to get
an education, US courts
have long required schools
to mitigate the harms of
this violence on student
victims' lives and to really
focus on victims' needs
in a way that the criminal
legal system doesn't and really
can't.
So I'm talking about how schools
must help victims relocate out
of a dorm that they
shared with their abuser
or off campus, free access to
a whole host of accommodations
like therapy and
academic tutoring
to help someone get back on
track in school after trauma.
And of course, the
system isn't perfect.
And certainly,
schools have all kinds
of incentives as corporations
with bottom lines
and reputations
at stake to get it
wrong to the detriment of both
victims and accused students.
Though you wouldn't know it from
how the media covers the issue,
young feminists have been
thoughtfully thinking
through what just discipline
should look like, too,
and what protections a
just disciplinary process
ought to have for
both students--
victims and accused.
So things like ensuring that
both parties have access
to all the evidence
and adequate time
to prepare their case,
that both parties are
able to have a
neutral third party
pose them questions
and examine them,
that both parties have the right
to appeal the decisions that
are handed down.
And it's not just in schools
that we're thinking about this,
but young feminist
groups like Know Your IX
have been really
active in opposing
the expansion of the
criminal legal system in sort
of a unique way that, as
survivors, we're able to.
So a couple years ago, we
defeated this Delaware bill,
which was backed by second-wave
Democrat lawmakers that
would force schools to hand
rape reports over to the police
with or without
survivors' consent.
And those bills, which have
really proliferated in states
all across the
country, don't just
undermine survivor autonomy.
They also limit the
range of options
that survivors
can pursue, making
victims who have reason to fear
the police afraid to report
to anyone, including
their school.
Likewise-- and I'll wrap up in
a minute-- but this last year,
Know Your IX and other groups
opposed the recalled Judge
Persky.
He was the judge who
gave Brock Turner
that infamous six-month sentence
for raping an unconscious woman
at Stanford.
And certainly, the sentence
that Persky imposed
was sexist and
racist and classist
and was rooted in the idea that
white boys who swim at Stanford
deserve endless second chances.
But the response of recalling
the judge we feared would cause
other judges to issue ever
more punitive rulings,
afraid of losing their
jobs if they didn't.
Anyway, the point
of our critique
here isn't to shame survivors
who choose to go to the police.
In a world with really
severely limited options,
it's understandable
to seek recourse
wherever you can find it.
And the point also isn't
to insist that Title IX is
a perfect alternative here.
I don't think it is.
Rather, it's to say this,
which is that we shouldn't have
to be afraid in our schools.
And we shouldn't have to choose
between enduring harassment
in our workplaces and not
bringing home a paycheck.
We need alternatives
beyond the criminal system
to make right the harm that
violence creates in our lives.
And we need systems
that discourage
that harm in the first place.
I think this is one of the
central questions my generation
is going to need to figure out.
And I feel really
glad that there
are so many smart,
creative young feminists
in that fight with us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi, feminists.
How are you doing?
I feel much more
nervous than I usually
do with public speaking.
And I think it's sort
of that thing where--
and maybe these other
panelists will agree with me--
when people I know or people
I love or my people are
in the audience, I often feel--
do the stakes feel higher?
In a way, that's
sweet but scary.
And I sort of feel that here
because I feel like probably
because you're my
people in many ways.
So thank you for being
here and making me nervous.
And I am so honored to be here.
I also feel a little bit out
of my depth in many ways.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Thank you.
Thank you, [? Jane. ?]
I take that back.
And I'm just going
to say that it also
feels sort of sweet
in a personal way,
because when I was--
about 20 years
ago when I was 16,
I dropped out of high
school and got my GED,
and I moved to Boston
and I took night classes
at Harvard Extension.
And I took mostly feminist
history classes and also
some creative writing.
And so it just feels
sweet, like I sort of
wish I could go back to
that very brave and arrogant
young person and let her know
that it was going to work out
and I would be here today.
So thank you for
allowing me that.
And you heard, I'm also
on the board of VIDA.
And with my colleague,
Hafizah, over here,
helped co-curate this event.
And you heard a
little bit about VIDA
from Jane in the introduction.
And I'll expand on
that a little bit more
to illustrate some
of the ways that I
think we are an example of a
certain kind of feminism now.
So for those of you who don't
know, almost 10 years ago now,
the VIDA founders,
who are all poets,
were having a conversation
with each other about the lack
of gender parity that
they saw in the magazines
where they wanted
to see their work
and in the review
outlets where they wanted
to see their work reviewed.
And it was a conversation
that they, of course,
had had before, that women
have always been having.
But they decided to concretize
what they were seeing.
And they wanted to make
other people see it.
Because they were
tired of making
that really obvious argument.
So they undertook this
massive data collection
and collected
hundreds of the years
tables of contents and
physically counted the women
that they could recognize.
And they counted reviewers,
authors of books reviewed,
and bylines in top-tier
magazines like The New Yorker
and so forth.
And the pie charts that resulted
proved what they already
knew, that women were profoundly
under-represented in all
of those spaces.
And in the 10 years since
then, the annual VIDA Count
has become something of a
household name, at least
among writers.
And many of those early and
worst offenders, the somewhat
repentant ones or at
least publicly repentant
ones, as Jane pointed
out, have admitted
to consciously working to
improve their VIDA numbers.
And since then,
in these 10 years,
VIDA has also grown in
some other directions.
Kimberle Crenshaw, who coined
the term "intersectionality"
and the analytic framework
said recently in an interview
that "intersectionality is
the lens through which you
can see where power
comes and collides,
where it interlocks
and intersects.
It's not simply that there's
a race problem here, a gender
problem here, a class
or LGBTQ problem here.
Many times that
framework erases what
happens to people who
are subject to all
of these things."
And Fatimah also
talked about this some.
I've worked primarily with
sort of the second generation
of VIDA leadership, along with
my two colleagues who are here
today, Hafizah Geter
and Camille Rankine, who
is our present executive
committee chair.
Can you guys just wave?
These women have done so
much work for this event
and in general.
[APPLAUSE]
And in recent
years, VIDA's focus
has broadened in this
consciously intersectional
direction, because we
don't just have a gender
problem in the literary world.
And the count is now plural
and examines race, disability,
sexual identity, and age.
And it's ever expanding.
And we're refining
our techniques
for counting those categories.
So the priority of VIDA
today is a bit broader
than it was in the beginning.
It's to examine and
raise consciousness
about these interlocking and
intersecting systems of power
in the literary world, which
is, of course, a microcosm
of our greater world,
and to create spaces
on stages like this,
in our online magazine,
and through programs
like saferLIT
where those most disempowered
intersectional voices can
be heard and protected.
So I'm here on this panel
as a VIDA board member
but also as a feminist artist.
So I want to talk a little
bit about my own path
and the relationship between my
art and my activism and the way
that our work at VIDA is sort
of at the nexus of those things.
So I'm on the cusp of
what some recognize
as the millennial cutoff.
And I was raised by a very
serious second-wave feminist,
by which I mean that as a
tiny person in a stroller,
I spent a lot of time
lounging at marches.
And when I learned
to read, I discovered
that my mother had corrected
all of my fairy tale books
with a Sharpie to
change the pronouns so
that the female characters
got most of the heroism.
It was Gretel who came up with
the idea with the bread crumbs
in my book.
And my bedtime lullabies
were Holly Near songs.
Anybody here-- yes.
OK.
"Power" was my favorite.
And my first concert was Sweet
Honey in the Rock, probably
still the best.
The first literary
accolade that I ever
won was a poetry prize
for girls from NOW,
the National
Organization for Women,
which as Jane pointed out,
houses their archives here
at the library.
- We have Holly Near, too.
- You have Holly Near also?
We'll talk.
The meetings of
whose local chapter
I regularly attended with
my mom and her friends
and played with my
LEGOs in the back.
I was also obsessed
with Ms Magazine.
And I borrowed the name
of its back page column.
I don't think they've
done this for a while,
but does anybody
remember "No Comment."
It was like readers would
send in misogynistic ads,
and they would collage
them on the back.
They never published
the ads that I sent in.
But I loved it so much,
that I named my zine
when I was 14 after
the back page of Ms.
And it was also
called "No Comment."
And I photocopied the issues of
my zine at our local library,
and then I distributed them
at my small-town high school
in Cape Cod.
I was very popular, as you can
imagine, as the only girl who
shaved her head but not her
legs in my whole school, who
was an out bisexual, who
knew all the words to Bikini
Kill and Ani DiFranco.
I literally can't
remember a time
when I didn't
identify as a feminist
or I didn't know that I
wanted to be a writer.
And I became conscious
of my own privilege
and my own intersecting
identity around the same time
that Crenshaw coined the term,
although it was another 20
years or so before I heard it.
Though I've always
identified as white
and experience the privileges
of being read that way,
I come from an
interracial family,
which felt really simple in
some ways inside of our home
and more complicated in other
ways outside of our home.
And it wasn't until college,
until I came here, actually,
that my understanding
of feminism
included a larger
dialogue about race.
And even then, it didn't really
dig into those more nuanced
intricacies.
I'm also the queer
daughter of a queer mother.
But as femme-presenting
women, we
have often been invisible
and assumed straight.
And in my early 20s,
I became a sex worker.
And the discourse
around that experience,
even among feminists, maybe
especially among feminists,
didn't seem to leave room
from my own experience.
So all of these aspects, and
not only these aspects of me,
felt fraught, laden with
both privilege and erasure.
And the feminism
I'd grown up with
didn't give me a map for
how to parse that out,
how I could be both marginalized
and privileged at the same time
or how to reconcile all of
those hybrid identities.
I felt so many
things that I just
felt like I could claim
nothing, a lot of the time.
So writing became a place really
early on for me, really young,
where I tried to put words
to the aspects of myself
and my world that felt unnamed,
even within my own politics.
And it has always been
that, a place where
I try to speak what feels
unspoken, discouraged,
incomprehensible, incompatible.
And as a teacher, that's how I
present writing to my students.
And that practice has
defined both the content
and the form of my work.
So I write mostly
nonfiction, but I
borrow elements of poetry
and memoir and scholarship
and criticism.
And like me, it's a hybrid
thing most of the time.
And when I finally did
find the literature
of intersectionality, it
felt like this huge relief
to see it named.
And that more holistic view
of our culture's sickness,
its fundamental
power imbalances,
seems, to me at least, also
to reflect the interconnected
nature of my own identity
and my work and my activism
and my art.
None of it is separate for me.
And so working with VIDA
seems like the perfect example
of that integration.
All of us at VIDA are feminists,
writers, teachers, editors,
folks who often claim the
intersectional identities
that we champion.
And we're all interested
in leveraging our privilege
to further that cause.
We each bring to
the organization
our own particular strengths
and employ them in our activism.
And it's part of our
art and our social lives
and our professions.
And I think it's
impossible for a lot of us
to distinguish those things.
And in that way, I
think we're really
typical of a certain kind
of contemporary feminism.
And I can see the ways that
my mother's feminism grew out
of that of the suffragists, how
it complicated and corrected
and advanced much of that work.
And I can also see the way the
third-wave feminists grew out
of and reinvented the
consciousness-raising groups
of the '60s and '70s.
And I can see the
ways that my feminism
and its intersectional
focus is a correction
to the history of
white feminism,
to Betty Friedan's fear
of the lavender menace,
as I can also find its early
echoes in the Bill of Rights
for NOW, which was
adopted in 1967
and speaks explicitly
about the need
for economic and racial justice.
So-- I'm almost done--
feminisms now, I think, are the
result of centuries of mindful
feminist work, the
work of activists
who recognize that
if we are going
to sustain our work, our
waves, but not troughs,
we needed a more expansive
space for feminism.
We needed a feminism
capacious enough for us
to work together and also
alongside one another.
We needed multiple feminisms.
And I do think
that we have them.
I think that you're looking
at them, in many ways.
And I'll end with a quote
from one of my heroes, one
that I was reminded
of recently in a talk
by the wonderful feminist
novelist Randa Jarrar.
So at the 1981 conference of
the American Writers Congress,
which sounds fancy, but
it was really small,
Toni Morrison, who was an
editor then at Random House,
told the audience, "We
don't need any more
writers as solitary heroes.
We need a heroic
writers' movement,
assertive, militant,
pugnacious."
And those words-- writing
them gave me a chill.
Reading them-- they make my
armpit hair stand up on end.
Because I think we actually
have right now not one
heroic feminist movement,
not solitary feminist heroes,
but a wide-ranging set of
heroic feminist movements.
Because the feminists I work
with today, these people,
they are as flexible and
creative and connected
as they are assertive,
militant, and pugnacious.
So I want to thank them
and thank you and thank
my fellow panelists.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi, guys.
First of all, I have to say,
as was mentioned earlier,
I graduated from Harvard.
I am always overjoyed
every single time
I get to come back here.
Every single time
I'm invited back,
I want to jump out of my skin.
Because I'm one of
those people who's
obsessed with their alma mater.
I used to really make
fun of the people.
Like, really?
That was the best
time of your life?
But it was.
And also, I am always so
happy to come back to Harvard,
because I do not
arrive at this work
if I didn't choose this place.
I was dumb as hell when I was
17 years old, as most of us are.
But I am so, so thankful
that stupid 17-year-old Kim
had the foresight
to choose Harvard,
because I'd not become the black
feminist media-maker that I
am if not for the
African-American studies
department, if not for the
feminist theory classes
that I was able to take here,
if not for the robust community
of black women that I
encountered when I was here.
So I am always delighted
to come back and be
of service to Harvard College.
[APPLAUSE]
So after I got that
out of the way--
so I started For Harriet
in 2010 when I was 20.
That was eight years ago.
How old am I?
I don't know.
So anyways, it was the spring
of my junior year in college.
I'm not going to get
into the whole story.
But basically, I
was politely asked
by Harvard College after junior
year not to return in the fall.
And so I was kicked
out of school.
I failed out.
But I came back and graduated.
It's a whole long story.
We can, you know--
But that summer, I
launched For Harriet.
And it was a digital community.
It is a digital community
for black women.
And at that point, my
desire was to create
intergenerational conversations.
I was incredibly lost.
I was stressed out.
I recognized how
important and how
fortifying the deep
connections that I
had developed with black
women of different ages
here had been for me.
So I wanted to recreate
that space online.
So originally, For Harriet
was about dialogue.
At that point, I was
already a progressive.
I was already a feminist.
And so I knew that I wanted For
Harriet to be an intentionally
progressive space, an
intentionally feminist space,
where we encourage dialogue,
but the kind of dialogue that
was going to move us forward.
And from starting this
community in 2010,
I was able to be really
plugged into black women's
digital spaces.
So this was way back when
everybody had Facebook,
but not really.
And it was the earlier
days of Twitter.
And Tumblr was a big deal.
So there were so many ways for
us to communicate and dialogue.
And I wanted to be able to
be a leading voice there.
I decided not to
script this out.
I did a talk about a month
ago, and it was so scripted,
and I realized the script
was a straight jacket for me.
So we're going to
loosey goosey it here.
All right.
So I always want to
underscore that I
am a very proud feminist.
I am amazed by the way
that feminist ideas
have been mainstreamed.
But I always want to
underscore that we do not
get to this place societially.
We do not get to
the MeToo movement.
intersectional feminism
without the work and the
theory of black women.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
It is so interesting
to me the way
that intersectionality
has been mainstreamed.
The other day, my mom, who
is not a feminist per se,
said, oh, it's the
intersectionality.
And I said, it's the what?
But that is because
these ideas that
used to be confined to
the, quote, unquote,
"ivory tower," they
have worked their way
into popular discourse.
And that has only happened
because of the work
that black women have
been doing online.
Often when we talk about
the digital divide,
we talk about how black
folks have less opportunity
to access digital technologies.
Sorry, my contract is about
to do something weird.
We often talk about
the digital divide
as coming from a
place of black, right?
Black people don't have access
to the newest technologies.
But I think that we see--
and the way that
black women's work
has infected mass movement--
I mean, we don't get
to the Women's March
without the work of black women.
I think of that divide as a
source of enormous opportunity.
Black women have
used these spaces--
Twitter, Facebook,
Tumblr spaces--
that were not made for us.
And they were not
made with us in mind.
But we have innovated
in these spaces
and been able to shape
and craft this discourse
in this back-and-forth and
doing this real-time theorizing
and doing it in a
way that sticks.
And that is really,
really incredible.
And so for me at For
Harriet, as I've gotten older
and grown in my
feminism, I wanted
to not just have dialogue.
But I wanted to cultivate
the sort of dialogue
that moves us forward.
Patricia Hill Collins says
in Black Feminist Thoughts--
I do a lot of citation.
I think a robust citational
practice is really important.
It's a really important
part of my feminism.
Patricia Hill Collins notes
in Black Feminist Thought
that the way that we transform
societies is twofold.
So it's doing that
internal work,
changing how you understand
yourself and the world.
And then you do
the external work,
like changing power relations.
And so I love doing the work
in black women's communities
of working on that
internal stuff
and making sure that
it goes outward.
So like I said, whenever I make
videos or whenever I'm tweeting
or whenever I'm editing
or writing articles,
I make sure to cite
the black women
theorists, the black
women activists who
have set the stage for
what we are doing now.
And it's really important for
me to do that because I often
find black women have--
they are not so apt,
often, to embrace
the idea of being feminists.
People say, I'm not a feminist.
I'm a womanist and
all of this stuff.
Because they imagine
feminism as being something
that is for white women.
One of the reasons why I have
a robust citational practice
is to underscore the fact
that we don't just get here,
that black women built this.
This house of black
women and women
of color, the house that we
are currently standing in
is not just a house that we
just walked in in 2015, right?
It is a house that we
constructed brick by brick.
That is our labor.
That is our work.
That is our activism.
That is our theory.
And so I always want to
be able to communicate
to black women of all
generations that this is us.
This is ours.
A long time ago, Barack Obama
said, you didn't build that.
No, we did build this.
We did build this.
And so another part of the
work that I am doing now
at Four Harriet and the work
that I'm doing personally
as I'm working on
this book project
is trying to outline what does
a feminist life look like?
Not to steal from Sara Ahmed.
She has an amazing book,
Living a Feminist Life.
But really approaching
that question
from the unique positionality
of a 29-year-old black woman,
a millennial black woman, whose
feminism has been constructed
by all of those women who
came before but has also
been constructed and mediated
by digital technologies
and the opportunities that
arise from those spaces.
What do we do?
And so I really want to
underscore for my community is
I don't love how a lot of
times when we're talking
about liberation, a
really popular approach
is to approach
liberation from a really
individualized perspective.
So I often hear
people say, liberation
is whatever it
feels like to you.
Liberation is whatever--
And I'm like, no.
[? I don't want. ?] Right?
So one of the things that I
try to underscore in my work
personally and the work
that we do For Harriet
is to underscore that
pleasure is important.
Pleasure is important.
We are human beings.
And it is important for
us to enjoy our lives
while we're here.
But I urge people to
interrogate those pleasures.
I think joy is important.
I live for my
five-year-old nieces.
I just am obsessed with them.
I want to be with them.
No-- I was to lie.
I was going to say I
want to be with them
every second of the day.
I do not.
But I love to hang
out with them.
I never experience
more joy than when
we are laughing and giggling.
That is important.
But I also want to underscore
our community and the people
who are drawn to my
work that we have
to interrogate how our joys
bring other people pain.
And that doesn't
mean that we have
to live in that place of shame.
It doesn't mean that we have
to be self-flagellating.
It just means that we
have to be conscientious
as we move through the world.
Another part of what I try to
do is to underscore the fact--
in doing a lot of research,
I have talked and interviewed
a lot of OG black feminists.
I read all the time.
That's a part of my robust
citational practice.
And I try to underscore the
fact that sometimes, especially
online when we're just
trading these thoughts
and theorizing really,
really quickly, we
have a tendency to think that
we are reinventing the wheel.
So take for example,
sexual bodily autonomy.
Sometimes I see young feminists
talk about bodily autonomy
and freedom with their
sexuality like we're
the first people who did this.
And so one of the things
that's so interesting to me--
I love, I love
interviewing elders--
is listening to a 75-year-old
black woman talk about, yeah,
I brought my girlfriend
to Thanksgiving in '72.
Yeah, we were out here with
boobs out and butt out,
and I had my hot pants in '67.
You know what I'm saying?
We are not the first
people to do this.
And that's why a big part of
my feminism, while I think
that contemporary feminism
is altering our conversation
in a very unique way, it's
also building on the shoulders
of those who came before.
And so I always want
to underscore that.
And finally, I
love what Dana was
talking about in her approach
to addressing sexual violence.
A big part of what I try to
do as a black feminist who
will hopefully write
a book of theory--
I am obsessed with theory.
Bell Hooks says in theory
is liberatory practice.
Theory has helped me
understand I'm not crazy.
And I want to help
other people understand
that they're not crazy.
But hopefully, what I'm going
to be doing in this work
is letting people know
that different is possible,
that we don't have to settle
for what we've been given,
that it looks hard
and sometimes it's
not easy for us to imagine.
What is a world without prisons?
Well, what does that look like?
But we can still
make steps forward.
A new world is possible.
So that's really what
I'm I'm trying to do.
[APPLAUSE]
- How's this microphone?
Good?
OK.
Cool.
Hello, people.
Hi.
This is my baby, [? Adrie. ?]
And over there is my nephew,
[? Shakur, ?] who's
doing a campus visit.
So I think you made a good
sell for the University,
for a young back
man to study here.
Anyway, my name is Emi.
I am currently
[INAUDIBLE] my work.
Lots of my work has to do
with the impact of policies
on people who are
in the sex trade,
and especially the kind of
policy that's rolled out.
And suppose they
do protect people
from the human
trafficking, especially
sex trafficking of
young people, but how
those policies in practice
impact the young people who
are often runaways, who
are queer and trans youth,
or the other people who
are in the sex trade who
are immigrants and
people of color
and how those
policies are actually
adding onto the
existing state violence
against those very
same communities.
So that's my main work.
But since this is a 75th
anniversary for the Schlesinger
Library, and I was
reminded about the article
that I wrote in 1999 about a
Transfeminist Manifesto, which
was like trying to write
transfeminism when there wasn't
even very much writing
about trans issues
in the first place.
Kate Bornstein's
Gender Outlaw was out.
Leslie Feinberg's book on
Transgender Warrior was out.
But there was basically
nothing else that was there.
And so it happened in 1999.
How long ago is that?
If there are any students
here, some of the students
weren't even born.
1999 is when Brittany was
singing "Hit Me One More Time."
[LAUGHTER]
TLC's "No Scrubs."
OK.
So that's 1999.
SpongeBob just started in 1999.
Columbine High School
shooting was 1999.
It's a long time ago.
And it's just so unbelievable
to think that the whole trans
movement and trans
awareness was,
like, zero at the time
compared to it is now.
And I was writing about
transfeminism at the time
and trying to write
about the [? how-- ?]
in both ways for the trans
to feminism and the feminism
to trans.
So I wanted to write about
how the key feminist issues
and concepts and
movements and focuses
on the feminist politics
and how those apply
to trans women and other
trans people and people who
are gender nonconforming,
which was not the language I
used at the time.
By the way, at the
time, the language
was transsexual, because there
are lots of older transsexual
people at the time
who are saying,
don't call me transgender.
That's not right.
So whatever.
That's old battles
from the 1990s.
So I was using the
word transsexual
to talk about that, how
those feminist politics,
feminist theory,
feminist movement,
apply to trans women
and other people.
And on the other hand, we're
talking about how involving,
including trans women's
lives and experiences changed
feminism.
So how does that inform when you
look at the ideas of privilege,
especially when people
talk about male privilege
and other privileges,
too, people
think in terms of people
have it or not have it,
just static and
totalizing things.
But that's not reality
in actual practice.
And I think that's true
for any other people, too.
But when you talk about
trans women's involvement
in feminism, that
makes even more clear
that this idea of totalizing
and static privilege
is not a real thing.
And I think that that's kind
of, in fact, one of the examples
that I think that trans
feminism brings to the feminism.
So I was writing about that.
And again, as I said, it's 1999.
It was limited because
of the historical--
the terms that I
used at the time
are not legible today
to people who are not
aware about the history.
And it's a historical text, even
though it's only 20 years old.
It's a historical
text that requires
the [? historisizing ?]
to understand
what those things mean.
When they talk about
how there is virtually
no representation of trans
men, which is not true now.
But the time, it
was very much true.
We had a couple of
friends who are trans men.
But there wasn't
any organization
that was headed by trans men
at the time, for example.
So that was actually
true at the time.
And it's a totally
different time now.
So there are weaknesses
because it's historical.
And also there was
weakness, because I
was writing in a near void.
And there was very
little published.
And especially there
was very little
published about transfeminism.
And there was very
little published
about trans women of color.
I didn't know
about Sylvia Rivera
or [INAUDIBLE] at the
time I was writing this
because nobody was
writing about that.
There wasn't blogs.
I mean, 1999, people
started writing some,
you know, what is that?
Like a diary thing.
And the weblogs started
happening in 2000.
And that became blog
a little bit later.
So there wasn't those.
There wasn't Tumblr.
There wasn't Facebook.
There wasn't any
of those things.
And so I was writing
without those things.
I was relying on books
and magazine articles.
And those are things
about white trans people.
There was nothing else.
So some of the weakness from
the [? manifest ?] that I feel--
and I kind of feel
embarrassed that sometimes,
some of the universities
are using that text when
from 1999 as if a contemporary
cutting-edge piece, which
it's not.
Is something that was written
at a certain historical moment
that is not now.
And I think it could be
beneficial if people actually
read that way.
But to use it and
show people, hey,
this is a really cool new thing,
and then that's so backward.
So it's been 20 years.
And I wanted to think about--
oh, my [? Adrie ?] is just
inside this.
She's just completely hidden.
So transfeminism in the 20 years
and how it changed or how it--
on one hand, we have rapid
and just explosive explosion
of the trans movement
and trans awareness,
trans visibility over
the last 20 years.
That was so much
hidden at the time.
But it's much more visible
that there are so many people,
so many trans
people who are out,
so many trans people who are in
the media, and who [INAUDIBLE]..
And also there are so
many trans allies who
are feminist and non-feminists.
And so we see all
of those, and it
seems that because we have maybe
100 times as many feminists who
are trans allies,
you might think
that transfeminism is 100
times stronger because of that.
But on the other hand, I feel
that even though this wide
acceptance and awareness
have spread about [? trans ?]
[? issues ?] in general,
the transfeminism--
it's like sharp awareness of
the interaction between trans
women's experiences with the
feminist ideas and movements
hasn't really happened except
for those few philosophy
journals you see some of the
really radical writing about.
That's not what
people are reading.
Well, what I noticed is that
there was too much emphasis
on respecting individual
identities, individual gender
identities, and
respecting the pronoun.
That was part of
the introduction
that was read about me.
So people just respecting
that somebody is--
somebody's gender
identity and pronouns.
And they end there, because
that's a test of whether or not
you are a trans ally.
But that's so limited.
That's just the basic.
That's assumption.
That's a premise, and
that's a [INAUDIBLE]..
That's a starting point.
But that's not the end.
That doesn't make
you a trans ally
or you make your task as
a trans ally end there.
And yeah, that's how it ends.
And I was just talking earlier
with [? Naomi ?] [INAUDIBLE],,
who wrote in 1995, I think, that
it in the context [INAUDIBLE]
lives, but transsexual
lives are lived and livable.
This is something that
was written in 1995
or-- is it 1995?
- 1997.
- Something.
Yeah.
It's before the Manifesto.
And by the way, I didn't
know that work in 1999
when I wrote the Manifesto.
I met her around 2000, 2001.
And so that's the idea that
we need to take the trans life
and existence as given.
It's for granted.
We're not debating that.
People exist, and we
don't need to have
any theoretical
justification for that.
People exist.
And then talk about
what we need to make
people's lives less horrible.
But that doesn't
happen very much.
We think that when we
respect someone's identity
and we respect somebody's
principal pronouns, that's it.
That's the end of it.
And that's how the bar
for the being trans allies
has been set so low, that just
by satisfying that, somehow you
escape any further
requirement to do something,
to address that kind of violence
and inequality and poverty
all the things that affect
the people who are trans.
And this is like a neoliberal
politics privilege [INAUDIBLE]
individual liberty to identify
who they are, reduces gender
to the individual preferences.
But gender is not just
individual preferences.
It's a [INAUDIBLE] social
stratification and violence as
well as of resistance
and liberation.
So that when you don't look at
that, when you think of it only
as a label you put on yourself
and then other people just
need to respect that,
that removes this
from the social context where
people are actually living.
The trans terms and
concepts are often
defined in a removed,
anti-feminist, even,
[? reactionary ?] ways.
People define trans
as somebody who
is born with a body
that's different from how
they identify.
And they say, well, the cis,
that's opposite of a trans,
for those people who
haven't heard it.
People often define cis means
that you are born with a body
and you're fine with the gender
that you are assigned with.
And if the being fine with the
gender you are assigned with
was what makes you cis, this
then feminists are not cis.
Feminists are not OK with the
kind of gender, the imposition
of gender that's placed on us.
And yet, that really
diminishes the reality
that cis is actually real.
Trans people do experience
a certain limitation
and restriction in life.
So it's a real thing that
we need to talk about.
But by defining it in such
a [? reactionary ?] way,
that it makes it lose meaning.
So often it's just
really poorly defined.
And this happens because we
remove the trans politics
and transfeminism from
the realities of how
people experience in our lives.
But there was one time the
trans movement has actually
gone more intersectional,
[? especially ?] in 2014.
That's the year in
January [INAUDIBLE]
was released from prison.
She was a black trans women
who was put in the men's prison
for defending herself.
And then she when she came out,
she and the black trans women
actress Laverne Cox,
went around in the media
and around the country talking
about prison abolition, prison
reform, prison
abolition, actually,
talking about how
the prison is just
not a good thing
for trans people
and that we shouldn't just
be looking at the pronouns.
We need to be thinking
about prisons.
In February, Janet
Mock's book-- she's
another black trans
women who's also
mixed-race in Hawaii, an
indigenous Hawaiian woman,
released the book, Redefining
Realness in February 2014.
And in June, the Laverne Cox,
the black trans woman actress,
was on the cover of Time
Magazine with the title
The Transgender Tipping Point.
And then in January
2015, we saw the release
of the film The Tangerine.
How many of you
have seen Tangerine?
Watch it.
It's [? the ?] best film.
I love it.
It's about the black
trans women who are doing
sex work and all kinds of--
their community and all the
crazy shit that happens.
You should watch it.
It's amazing.
It's comedic.
And it shows the trans women,
black trans women, characters
as acted by black trans
women and beautiful.
Anyway, there was a rush of
this focus on black trans women.
And black trans women
somehow dominated
the public representation of
a trans issues for a while.
And it's not just
only the black trans
women that were on the
cover of magazines.
But they were talking
about prison abolition.
And that has never
happened before.
And then that dominance
of the black trans
women in the media and all
that died down quickly in 2015.
What happen in 2015?
Do you know?
2015, what happened
was Caitlyn Jenner.
Caitlyn Jenner, who
supported Donald Trump.
Caitlyn Jenner, who said
to the Vanity Fair magazine
the hardest part
about being a woman
is figuring out what to wear.
So she became the face of the
transgender people in America.
And along with that, we saw the
rise of the anti-trans bathroom
bills around the country.
So they're trying to restrict
trans people's access
to bathrooms.
So with all of those--
and also I feel like both the
gay rights and anti-gay rights
movements used the
bathroom issue because they
lost the issue of marriage.
The marriage was--
the Supreme Court,
everything might come back.
But for the moment, it
was resolved nationally.
So they needed some issue
to rally around their people
and raise more money so they
went to the bathroom issue
on both sides.
And how this bathroom
bill controversy happened
was that it reduced-- the
whole idea of bathroom access
is way more political than just
whether or not trans people can
use the bathroom.
We think about trans
inclusion, but we also
think about the access for
homeless people and people
using drugs in the
public bathrooms
because there are no
other safe place to do so.
The politics around racial
segregation was a thing.
There is sexual violence,
sexual harassment in restrooms.
The bathroom in
certain communities
was the site for
cruising for sex.
So there's lots of politics
and culture behind that.
And then also we have--
it's just so funny.
So many cafes around
in Seattle where I live
have a sign that says all are
welcome, immigrants welcome.
And then bathroom
for customers only.
No public bathroom.
At the same-- next
to each other.
And then when you think
about the establishment
of quality-of-life crime
laws which makes it
a crime for people to lie
down in the street or pee,
urinate in the street
and things like that.
And those are specifically
targeting certain communities.
So there are so many
political things
that are involved in this idea
about bathroom access itself.
And yet it's just reduced
to who gets to access--
which person gets to
access which bathroom?
And they're not thinking
about homeless people.
They're not thinking about
other people who are--
people with disabilities
who can't access bathrooms.
They're only thinking about
which white trans women can
access women's restrooms.
That's how reduced
that issue is.
We need to not do this.
We need to go back to the--
oh, [? Adrie-- ?] we need to
think about the gender justice
and gender liberation, not
the gender libertarianism,
where you get to decide
which gender you are.
We need the public spaces
reimagined radically,
not just the
gender-appropriate bathrooms
and designating the gender
policies for each facilities.
And we need prison
abolition and not
gender-sensitive prisons
that can put people
in the right place.
And I want to end with
that what [INAUDIBLE] said
in the early interviews
right after she came out
of prison, when she was put in
the men's prison for two years.
And people lobbied,
organized to try to get her
to be transferred
to a women's prison.
But she actually
responded to that,
saying that, no, the
women's prison is not
an appropriate place
for me, either.
There's no appropriate place
in a prison for a black trans
women like her and
probably for nobody else.
So she was telling the
people, and many of those
are trans activists and
trans allies who are white,
who don't know
anything about prison--
I'm not saying that
white people don't know--
I'm talking about
people who have
no experience in
the prison activism
before are being introduced
to that through the work
of a black trans woman
who was in men's prison
and telling people, rather
than to fight the fact that she
was misclassified into men's
prison instead of women's
prison, we need to fight
to release and free
all trans women and all
black people and all people
from the prisons.
And so that's like a really--
it was really--
I don't know what to say.
It was really
exciting to see that.
And that became the call
of the trans movement
for a second in 2014.
I want to bring that back.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
- Wow.
Thank you so much.
It's interesting,
because one of the things
about our generations is that
we spend so much time thinking--
especially people who are maybe
a little bit older than you
guys, like me-- that we
spent so much time thinking,
oh, my gosh, we don't have
progressive intellectual life,
progressive cultural life,
where has it happened?
And it's just such
a pleasure to me
personally to be able
to be here with you guys
and to realize the amazing
work that you're doing
and the amazing
energy that you all
are bringing to your activism
and into your creative stuff.
Fatimah, I wanted to
say to you thank you so
much for your beautiful poetry.
It was just, frankly, fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]
And just you know, I'm a super
snob about literature so--
[LAUGHTER]
You're good.
And I just wanted
to say you had me,
and I think you set the
tone for this conversation
with that whole idea that
we don't want-- none of us
wants our identities to
be thought of as just lack
and trauma.
All of us are unbelievably
complicated people.
Dana, I love the
idea of the fact
that young feminists, some of
them survivors, many of them
survivors, are,
in fact, thinking
in sophisticated ways
about holistic responses
to sexual violence.
That is an amazing
and brave thing.
And you and the people that
you're doing your work with
need to be commended.
And I told you
earlier that I think
that the fact that
you have been involved
in an organization
of young people--
and training young people to
take over the organization
is an incredibly radical
thing to be doing,
radical in the best
sense of the word.
So thank you for that.
And Melissa, for
one thing, I wanted
to tell you that my
first-ever album was Queen
and my second ever album
I ever bought on my own
was Holly Near.
So I'm right there
with you on that.
And I still have that
Holly Near album.
And I got it signed by
Holly Near, no less.
And so I think that it's amazing
to have a generation of people
that's having a set of
cultural references built off
of feminism.
And thank you for
that conversation.
And I love it that
right at the beginning
of the process of
VIDA's development
you all were already
interested intersectionality.
So it was a question of
the genders of the writers
and the creative people
who were being included
but also their race
and their sexuality
and their age and their
ability or disability.
And then Melissa, I have
to say, excuse me, Kim,
I have to say to you that--
to thank you, actually,
because, in fact,
this is my second
week at Harvard.
And so I was like, well,
there is a robust community
of black women.
There is plenty of
feminist theory.
And there's both
women and gender
studies and African and
African-American studies.
So I'm psyched all up.
I'm psyched all up about it.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you very much.
And I couldn't
agree with you more
that we need to do better
citational practice.
And I'm a snob about
citational practice, in fact.
I, in fact, know what
I'm talking about.
And I think that
it's a point that
has to be driven home over
and over and over again.
And I really like this idea
of what does feminist life
actually look like and what
does a feminist future actually
look like?
And I'll go through
this quickly,
and then I'll ask all of
you this question exactly.
And Emi, obviously,
your comments
were so informative
and so brave.
It's rare that you have somebody
talk about their own work
and say, you know, this
work that I did 20 years ago
actually has its own limitations
that are based on the fact
that it was done 20 years ago.
And I bet you're a rougher
reader of your work
than everybody else is.
And then it's a bold
statement to say
that you believe that there's
too much emphasis on questions
of individual identities
and that what you believed
should happen, I
think, a lot of people
actually believe is-- the
phrase that you've said
is the public spaces should
be reimagined radically.
So I was stunned by what
you were saying, all of you.
But what kills me, what really
I can't get my head around,
is that we're here with
a group of very, very
impressive persons.
And [INAUDIBLE] are doing
all sorts of fantastic work.
I don't get it, how you can
have this community of people
engaging with this
community of people
and yet we're in a
time in our country
in which intersectional is
wildly under attack, when
there's a certain set
of identity politics
that have taken
over the government.
And so can you explain to us
how that weird bifurcation
is happening in our culture?
And then tell us
the way forward.
[LAUGHTER]
But I also should say that
we don't have so much time.
So you're going to need
to be quick about it,
because we want to have
questions and answer, too.
- I would say that
pushback is to be expected.
I'm not a historian.
But I do be reading.
And I got a degree in African
and African-American studies.
Shout out to [INAUDIBLE]
[? Skip ?] [? Gates. ?] So
anyways, I think we see
throughout history that
as people of color, marginalized
people make inroads.
There's always going to be
pushback from the mainstream,
from majority.
That power shift always causes
a mass revolt and pushback.
And so I'm not
necessarily surprised.
I heard an amazing writer
called [? Doreen ?] [? St. ?]
[? Felix ?] once.
She said that this
is just evidence
that white supremacy
is on its last breath,
you know what I'm saying.
So this historical
moment that we're in,
I don't consider it
to be a huge failure.
I consider it to be evidence
that we are on the right path.
[APPLAUSE]
- Can I ask you guys
back about that.
I tend to think
that that's true.
At the same time, what
about the question of people
right now in having to
deal with backlash in ways
that are quite deadly?
What do you say to communities
that really are getting it
in the neck?
There's lots of
[? spikes ?] of all types
of violence in this society.
How do we actually--
I agree that we're probably
moving ahead historically.
How do we care for each other
during what are very, very
difficult times for all of us?
I also will call on you.
I am a professor.
- I can't-- does this mic work?
No.
Yes.
So I think-- this is hard for
me because I'm not an academic,
I'm not an intellectual.
I'm an artist.
So all of my work
is contextualized
by the practice of art making
and by being an artist first.
And so thinking about the
kind of current age we're in,
I agree a lot with
Kim about the feeling
of this moment being a
response to the kind of hope
that folks had when Obama
was president and when folks
were like, oh, now
we're post-racial
or whatever that mass was.
But I think that as an
artist, though, we've been--
what you do is--
I don't know.
Whatever.
I've seen the ways
in which folks have
been suffering for forever.
This isn't to me--
and a lot of folks have asked
me when the book was coming out,
when Brown Girls was coming
out, I was like, well,
now's the time.
And I was like, now
is the time for what?
That's been happening.
This has been happening.
You read articles
from the '70s and '80s
of cops murdering young
black people in New York
and all over the country.
This is not-- all of
this stuff has just kind
of been happening for so long.
And it's really,
really frustrating
to feel like that has
continued to happen
and people's labor has continued
to happen around organizing
and being activists around it.
And then there is still such
daunting white supremacy.
That's a really
frustrating thing.
And to me, what I think
about it as an artist,
what is the role of art in that?
What is the role
of things that we
can do as artists to
both provide spaces
of alleviation and
of joy and also
to provide spaces of a
magnifying glass and a witness
to that?
And so that to me
is what I think
of as the responsibility
of an artist
is to say how can you
both be the magnifying
glass and the moments where
you can kind of build a shelter
for that feeling?
And I agree a lot with
Emi about the kind of ways
that it's really important
to radically reimagine
public spaces.
And I think that if there were
spaces in which we could have
public reckonings
with our history,
if there were spaces in
which that was named,
I think we would live in
a really different world.
And I think that
if we really had
to grapple where we walked on
a day-to-day basis, the things
that have happened in
the spaces we're around,
I think we would
just really live
in a really different world.
- So are you saying
that we should
do more monuments, more memorial
practices in the society
at large?
- I think so.
I mean, I think so.
I think that--
I did a Fullbright
in Bosnia where--
and it was 20 years after
the siege of Sarajevo.
And I was really interested
in the ways that--
I was looking particularly
at memorialization,
using art as a way of
memorializing violence.
And I think what I saw there.
And it's not perfect.
But what I saw was
moments in which
both through ephemeral
site-specific work
and through monuments
and through art,
and even just how
all the parks were
converted into grave
sites out of necessity.
There is a way when that
happens, you really grapple
with things.
And here, I think a
lot of American society
is just really interested in
the Band-Aid and the cover-up.
And I don't think that
that's a good thing.
- Can I ask all of you
a question that follows
from that, then, about--
especially because we're
talking about feminisms now
and we're talking about
millennial feminism in relation
to second-wave feminism--
how is it that
you do as feminist
the types of
understanding what has
come before the types
of memorialization
of previous ways of thinking
that actually can get
to large amounts of people,
that actually allows
us to not always be--
every one of you said something
about recreating the wheel.
And I'm not sure, as an
educator, that I know
how to not recreate the wheel.
I wonder if you guys
have ideas about how
to do a better job of that.
- I guess I will say--
and I'll also relate
this back to art,
because it's analogous for
something that comes up
in my teaching a lot, which
is that I get a lot of writers
being worried that
their work is going
to be reinventing the wheel or
that it's not totally unique.
And my answer to that
over the years has become,
it doesn't have to be.
Certainly there
is a way that you
are creating a work that could
be executed and delivered
in only the way that you
could possibly do that.
But its message is not
going to be a new one,
because the things that
we need to see in art,
as the things that we need
to address with our activism,
are not new problems.
So I'm really into
Kimberley's phrase
of robust citational practice.
So I think it's not--
I don't think there's a problem
with fighting the same fight.
Because we haven't won it yet.
It's about sort of giving
credit to the people who've
done it before and to adopting
correct strategies that
worked and didn't work.
- All right.
I'll ask one last
question on my own,
and then I think that we
have the microphone here
so we'll take some
questions from the audience.
So I get all that.
But how do you stay
robust yourselves?
It's an amazing thing to have
a robust citational practice.
It's an amazing thing to be
constantly doing your work.
But how do you make sure
that our communities
are caring for themselves and
in the fight for the long term?
I like the idea of you've got to
have pleasure in life as well.
And we all know that one of the
real tragedies of generations
of activists who came before
us is that so many of them
burned out, died early deaths,
had real financial problems,
had real substance
problems, everything.
So we would be wrong to not
note that and to try to say,
at least among ourselves,
look, these are the strategies
that one needs in order
to be an activist who
is a robust activist
and a robust person.
- Yeah.
I would recall what
Fatimah said about lack.
And what I see is its
converse, which is abundance
and gratitude and
joy and plenty.
And even in the midst of all
of these recurrent problems,
we all have that.
And I think most of
us referenced it.
And for me, I have to
feed that part of me that
is in touch with the abundance.
And that comes from
absorbing other people's art.
I talk about
therapy as much as I
can because it has been
so necessary to my art
and my activism and my
recovery and remaining robust.
And I think that talking
about self-care--
the term has a little
fatigued with that.
But there are forms
of wellness that I
think are radical, especially
for certain populations.
- I loved in
Fatimah's second poem,
I think it was, how to not get--
what was it?
- Hypothermia.
- Ever so sorry.
- Oh, that's OK.
- That the answer to that
was have your friends.
So self-care is also
about communities
caring for each other
and caring for each other
across differences as well.
- I also just want
to say really fast
that when I emphasize
to people my age
and younger generations
of women that we don't
have to recreate the wheel,
it is not necessarily
an admonishment.
It's the fact that-- look at all
of this incredible work that's
been done.
Look at this
incredible foundation
that we have to build from.
And then we don't have
to beat ourselves up
if we don't feel like we
have all of the answers.
And we don't have
to waste time trying
to retread these arguments
that have already been had,
trying to remake this theory
that's already been done.
We get to remix and remake.
And that's an
enormous opportunity.
She mentioned abundance.
I feel enormous gratitude
that we have that.
- Right.
That's fantastic.
So I think that we can
take a few questions.
I have been asked to
be that time police.
I don't like it.
I don't even believe in the
Western concept of time.
But I will knuckle under
for the time being.
If there are people who
would like to come to this
mic in the center, if
you'd like to ask questions
to our panelists.
And they do have all
the answers, by the way.
- Hello.
I just had a kind
of quick question.
As someone who's lived in
a lot of different areas
of the country, I've found--
I've only lived here in New
England for a few years.
But I've found
that there's often
this sense that this
very liberal area isn't
part of the problem.
And I wonder if you
have any suggestions
for sort of changing the
conversation around that.
- No.
[LAUGHTER]
- Can you clarify your question?
- Yeah, I'm not sure
I totally [INAUDIBLE]..
- I think that if I can
repeat what you said,
I think that you said that
you live here in this area,
in the Boston-Cambridge
area, and in liberal areas
the assumption is often that
we are not part of the problem,
the problem of woman-hating,
the problem of racism,
the problem of transphobia,
the whole thing, and--
- [INAUDIBLE]
- And so New England
is just now reckoning
with the violence
of slavery as well.
So how do you, in
New England, let's
say it that way, how
do you in New England
continue to do activism with
a population that imagines
that it's not the
problem, largely imagines
that it's not the problem.
- I would say one
thing that I'm obsessed
with writing about and
working through right now is
making sure that when we
are talking about power,
we are doing it in
interesting and complex ways.
So often we think about
power and privilege,
and it's I have more
than you or whatever.
And after reading this
book called The Metaphysics
of Gender by Charlotte Witt.
I'm sorry.
I'm one of those--
so anyway, I just
got finished reading
this book called The Metaphysics
of Gender by Charlotte Witt.
And actually, that's
not where this idea
is going to come from.
It's actually going to
come from Iris Marion
Young, who is a political
theorist and feminist theorist.
Anyways, after reading her
book, Justice and the Politics
of Difference, what I
really came away from
is this understanding that power
is not what individuals have.
Power is what societies do.
And when we refuse
to think about power
as just like, what am I
doing to you, getting away
from that interpersonal
stuff and really
think about what our society
is doing to people, what
is happening
structurally, I think
that people are more apt
to be able to understand
why is this person in poverty?
It is not necessarily a
personal indictment of you
when we take away
that stuff that
makes people uncomfortable,
even though it's
good to be uncomfortable.
We can think about
the ways that we
attain these social
positions structurally.
And I think that going back
to the work of black feminists
who tell us that all
oppressions are linked,
this idea of interlocking
depressions from the Combahee
River Collective, really
just underscoring the fact
that this stuff is structural.
Who cares about you?
Look at all of the
violence and the harm
that these white supremacist
capitalist imperialist
patriarchy is doing around us.
- Please.
- Hello.
My name is [? Aila. ?] And
I am a graduate student
in library and information
science at Simmons College.
And I also work here at
the Schlesinger library.
And I've been working
with Angela Davis
with her a collection
among others.
And I'm curious how
are you all thinking
about how you want
to be remembered
and how you want your
legacies to be formed?
- I like that question.
Emi, you have a funny
look on your face.
Go for it.
- I just hate taking
credit for things.
So I write lots of things.
And I try to offer analysis.
And I want that to have
an impact in the society.
I wanted to educate and inform
and just change conversations,
whether we were talking
about the politics
of [INAUDIBLE] people in the
sex trade or any other issues.
I've done lots of work around
changing the way the society
and especially
feminist institutions
deals with [INAUDIBLE]
sexual assaults.
Those are-- to me, it's
just all those ideas.
I mean, it's not like
my original ideas.
It comes in conversation
with lots of other people.
It's like I feel like I'm making
a contribution in those ways.
And I want those to
continue to ripple.
I don't really want my
name attached it it.
I'll be horrified if
something was named after me.
- Please.
- Hi, My name's [? Anata. ?]
I'm a student at the college.
I wanted to thank Kimberly
for the foundation of theory
and talking about
citation and making sure
we acknowledge and give homage
to those that came before us.
Emi, you talked about talking
about limitations for things
that had been done previously.
And in that vein, my question
is to Fatimah Asghar.
Watching your Brown Girl
series, studying it in class,
knowing that the first
line of the show is
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],, knowing
that that was said after
a young brown woman wakes up
from bed with another woman,
but also knowing the
history of how absolutely
LGBTQ-plus-filled
South Asian history is,
with the backdrop
just a few days ago,
the overturning of penal code
377 in India that now has
decriminalized being gay and
lesbian and all the wonderful
things of being part of
the LGBTQ-plus community.
I wanted to ask
you, as an artist,
do you feel a sense
of responsibility
of engaging within the
repertoire of lived experiences
in the archive of
history that is often not
explored in mainstream
America or in mainstream
Western society?
And if so, how do you
confront that responsibility
since we are also in
this weird position
of having privilege,
being in the west
and having that platform?
- Yeah.
I mean, I feel a tremendous
amount of responsibility
to so many people.
When I think about
my artist medium,
the thing that I
think most about
is, I think I deal-- my
medium is relationships,
and it's community.
That's it beyond anything.
And so everything
else, Brown Girls,
poetry, all of that
kind, that's kind
of like subservient to the
idea of that community piece
that's really, really
important to me.
And it's hard because I think--
I don't know if I'm
going to fully answer
your question because
it's something
that I'm kind of still grappling
with or think about a lot.
But I feel like there's so
much in terms of responsibility
in being an artist.
There's a responsibility to
the people you come from,
to the community, to
the lineage that's
behind you, to all of these
different folks that you're
in conversation with.
And then there's also
responsibility to self.
And there's responsibility
to just thinking
about what is your
truth and what
does it mean to not say that?
And my book, it's
pretty brutal in some
of my family relationships.
And that was a thing
that I had to navigate
with a lot of
responsibility, too,
is to think about how do I
be honest about things that
happened but how do I
still love the people who
maybe damaged me?
And how do you hold forgiveness?
And how do you hold that love?
And I think there's this
artist, Nick Cave, who I love,
who makes these really
beautiful soundsuits.
And once I was in
a lecture with him,
and he said this thing where
he said, you as an artist,
you're a vessel.
And you're a vessel.
And you're there to receive
and then to put out.
And everything else is ego.
So everything else about
wanting your name on something
or wanting whatever,
that's all ego.
And it's not actually
that important.
And so in terms of
thinking just about what
does it mean to be an
artist, specifically
a Pakistani [? Kashmir ?] artist
that's living in the West,
that's who I am.
So if my privilege is being a
Westerner, my kind of grappling
with the romanticism
of where I come from,
of understanding
histories of all of that,
and that constant rediscovery,
because there is a way that I
didn't grow up with that.
There is kind of
a real way where
I didn't know what partition
was until I was in my 20s.
So I didn't know this incredibly
important historical thing
that happened, that totally
influenced all of South Asia
until I was in my 20s.
And so there is kind of a want--
or what I find in my
own artistic practice
is the re-journeying
and the constant trying
to remember where I come
from and all of those things
that make me up but
also the responsibility
to my current self
and community.
I hope that answers
your question.
- Hi, everybody.
My name is [? Michelle ?]
[? Bent. ?] I'm a student
at Brandeis, studying masters
in sustainable international
development.
And my question to
all of you was I'm
interested in how gender
and evolving feminism can
translate into--
or how that would look into
the international realm?
For example, like sex
work or sexual violence
in conflict areas.
So how does your work or
the work you plan to do
or how does your feminism
reach internationally?
And how can the new generation
and robust feminists
reach the international lens?
- Wow.
Let's hear it.
- So in terms of sex workers'
rights and people's rights who
are in the sex trade, US is
far behind other countries.
So in the countries where--
countries like India, there are
mass movement of sex workers.
In the US, I mean--
this is not to be--
I'm not trying to say it's bad.
But the US sex worker movement
is vastly white middle class.
On the other hand,
in other countries,
it's actually a mass
movement of common people.
In India, in countries
like Taiwan or in Korea,
we have those mass
movements that
can actually do demonstrations
that can stop things.
And that doesn't
exist in the US.
And so I think that we need
to really learn from that
and try to figure out how they
were able to sidestep this sex
wars context of the US
feminism, where anything that
has to do with sex workers'
rights is put to the question
about whether or not this--
just having this idealistic
argument about whether the sex
work is good or bad for women.
And that's the kind of
abstract controversy
that doesn't really reflect
the reality of people living
in the situation and how to make
things better for the people.
And I think in other countries,
they're able to do that.
And that's something
that we want
to try to borrow from
the other countries
and trying to see how
it can be addressed.
In any other field
where there's lots
of violence and exploitation
and trafficking,
we're not going to go and try
to bust and prosecute everybody.
That's how the US deals
with the sex work.
But that's not how it is
in any other industry.
And it's telling that
they see in the US
this demonization of
pimps and traffickers
as men of color, whereas the
people who own the factories
and farms and hotels
where trafficking,
labor trafficking-- the
majority of trafficking
in the US labor trafficking.
And where those
things happen, those
are businesses
owned by white men.
And they're not demonized
in the same way.
And so [INAUDIBLE] I think that
kind of the US white supremacy
and kind of economic
elitism wars,
capitalist arrangements
really impact
that, how we see the
policies around sex workers.
So when I look at
internationally,
I feel like the
people need to realize
that even though we have more
organizations for sex workers'
rights in the US,
they're not advanced.
- Thank you.
And I think that we have
time for one more question.
- I'll be that one.
My name is Kafi Dixon.
I'm the founder
of a women's co-op
here in Boston, The
Common Good Project,
which is the first urban farm
focused on women of color
as a health care outreach and
as a community health hub.
So one of the things
that we're running into,
and this is directed
at you, Kimberly,
because that's what brought
me here from Dorchester
was you and the
rest of the panel,
but specifically looking
at some of the women that
are in our community
who may not specifically
identify with the word
feminist or feminism
but practice it in action
every day in their community.
And what we've been running
into over this last year
is how to connect those
35-plus women of color
with the new wave of young
academic students who
want to hold space with them and
help them resolve their issues
but do not necessarily--
the younger feminists
are not identifying with the
older feminists in their work.
And when you were talking about
dialogue between generations,
how do we connect?
What are some of the
best practices, Kimberly,
you can advise our
organization and connecting
an arc between those
generational understanding
of what feminism is
for women of color?
Sorry for that being
a lengthy question.
- Sure.
So I'll make it as
quick as possible.
So I think that there are--
black women are not a monolith.
But there are certain
sorts of experiences
that we can all connect to.
So most black women can identify
with feeling undervalued
by their employer or--
and this is just
from my experience
and from reading lots and lots
of black feminists texts--
we can identify with a
certain marginalization
in the workplace.
We can identify with
feeling disempowered
in our romantic relationships.
We can identify
with feeling like we
are [? mules ?] in our
interpersonal relationships,
in our familial dynamics.
I think that there are just
certain sorts of experiences
that cross generations, that
cross socioeconomic status.
The details of my
employer at my law firm
is going to be
different from the way
that your employer at your
restaurant job or service work
job--
the details of that stuff
is going to be different.
But those underlying feelings,
we can connect there.
And I think offering
people an open platform
to talk about those
experiences, the foundations
of those experiences,
and then get
into the intricacies of the
differences, the detail,
the dynamics, I think,
offers an opportunity
to have connection there.
I think that there's really
power in embracing difference.
And so I wouldn't
be afraid of the way
that those differences pop
up across our experiences.
- On that note, I want
to take the opportunity
to thank our fantastic
five panelists for a really
remarkable--
[APPLAUSE]